siberia has long been a byword for the
freezing cold
but this year russian towns across the
arctic circle
have been experiencing a prolonged heat
wave
generating extraordinary temperatures
[Music]
one town was nearly 40 degrees just a
few weeks ago
hard to imagine in years gone by this
was a place where
soviet leaders sent political prisoners
as punishment
because of the plunging mercury in
winter
the heat has triggered out-of-control
wildfires across
thousands of acres of forest prompting
siberia to come under the scrutiny
of a leading group of global scientists
they've run dozens of computer
simulations
to compare the climate in siberia as it
is today with about
one degree of global warming with the
climate as it would have been
without human influence how does this
study offer more
unequivocal evidence that climate change
does exist
compared to other studies the event that
we have looked at
this prolonged heat of a very large part
of of siberia for
um for for for the first six months of
this year
that would have been basically
impossible
to happen without a human induced
climate change
so it is really we are seeing something
new here that we would not have
seen if we had not burned all these
fossil fuels over the last 250 years
the planet is getting warmer this is
svalbard in the arctic
circle known for its frozen tundra and
glaciers which are now
melting fast temperatures in the polo
regions
are rising quickly because oceans carry
heat towards the poles
and reflective ice and snow is melting
away
year after year brings more extreme
weather
not everything can be attributed to
soaring global emissions
but the world weather attribution group
says many
other events like the devastating fires
in australia
six months ago were made more likely
because of climate change
it's all pushing the world towards
another unwelcome record
that it's on course in 2020 to become
the hottest year
ever lisa holland sky news